so one of the great things about
civilization is that there's a whole
bunch of different people all the
different people have different about
different things and somehow if they all
follow their own curiosity in some way
great stuff happens that's sort of
what's happened so far I mean if you're
in a civilization where you're able to
support people doing that then the
civilization feels you feel happier to
be in it i mean when i read about
something at whether it's art or biology
or sociology if i read about something
interesting and I realize that some
humans actually spent their whole life
doing Beth and it's and that we
supported them doing it I I feel like
that's the the the pinnacle of
civilization that's the best so I think
you know one of the reasons we fund
these experiments is because we want to
live in a world where people find stuff
out imagine if you funded nothing in
science and you never found anything out
how depressing would that be I don't
know actually how depressing would that
be that but that would be pretty
depressing or imagine a world in which
nobody could write books or yeah I think
the reason to fund things and of course
you can't argue that any stupid thing
you should have fun but if there's a
whole lot of people who are interested
in doing something and it makes sense
and they've worked on it for years it's
reasonable to fund it I think if you can
I mean there's some people who believe
that you know you should only fund
things that make people's lives longer
that seems ridiculous how about making
people's lives better how about people
making people happier to be alive
because they can read cool stuff the New
York Times or whatever wherever in
science so this so people are somehow
moralistic about the length of people's
lives rather than the quality of life or
the rather than the standard of living
so I think by me doing particle physics
it raises everybody's standard of living
that's a
boy maybe I shouldn't be quoted that way
I think I think I do